so what was it like diving into a
character with two personalities with a
stephen and mark and i feel like there's
in the first few episodes there's hints
at a third in there
it's very possible you'll have to keep
watching to find out i can't
thank you
but um that was actually for me that was
the the draw
to to be able to create
one incredible
indelible character and then also create
the counterpoint to that character um
you know and find the tension between
how they interact and how
uh really how it's revealed to stephen
that he's sharing his body with an
ex-mercenary in the service of an
egyptian deity what was it like when you
saw yourself in the final moon night and
mr night costumes i'm sure there were
iterations leading up to the final
version when you saw it all completed
what was your reaction
there's no doubt that i am in a marvel
superhero movie since i saw myself in
that i was like you know yes we were
working with all the psychological
aspects and all that but this this guy's
a superhero
it was you know very powerful you know
scary as well such an unusual design
um
yeah you know it felt like we were we
were
really pushing the genre into a into new
places
yeah how much of it is practical and how
much of it was was cgi
with the suit yeah
um i mean i'd say 90 was practical as
far as what yeah what i'm wearing i mean
you know some of the action moments you
know he'll be cgi but the suit itself i
mean that was the full-on thing the cape
the hood everything mask
that's amazing
it looks really great um
there's a fun moment when steven summons
the suit what was it like for you you're
as you said you're doing all the
psychological work you're going with you
know we're introduced to stephen first
with the story is mostly from his
perspective it seems like
and then he gets this dude who you know
has this sort of mundane life all of a
sudden is in a super suit himself of
discovering that he has some abilities
what was that moment like it's a very
cool scene well i mean that's that that
part of the journey is so fun because
we're introduced to this very
mild-mannered sweet awkward man who is
kind of desperate for a connection
and and he
he slowly discovers that he has all this
other
unknown life to him living inside of him
and so you know that was a really fun
thing to play with the you know the idea
that he has the power too but he can
manifest the suit into an idea of his
own which is this
three-piece very you know dapper suit
that he has
and so playing with the the humor of
that was a lot of fun so if there's a
potential third person in there um is
there a third iteration of the suit as
well i like how you're thinking that
it's very logical
it is or do can they can can mark summon
the mr knight suit
and vice versa question that's also a
really great question yeah
i don't know the answer to that
embrace the chaos
dude what was it like for you locking
down ethmoid abraham to voice konshu
i know it's amazing it's great it's like
our second project we get to do together
um no you know we were talking about
about the nature of of conscious voice
and you know uh the fact that that f
murray apart from just having an
incredible voice is also of syrian
descent so there is a tie to to the the
middle eastern mythology there and so it
just felt like he was the perfect person
to to bring the gravitas to that
character do you call him personally
like hey are you interested in this i
mean i mean i i i definitely reached out
to him and we started talking about it
we i talked to him about the character
and how how you know how i see him as a
representation of of the trauma and the
the punishment and the vengeance that he
that that mark is in a way enslaved to
um and so it was it was just great to
talk to him about all those things and
uh he's just one of my favorite actors
she did some interviews where he talked
about wanting to get the midnight suns
together blade punisher daredevil ghost
rider has kevin reached out and said
that's a great idea let's put this
together all these guys are cast in one
way shape or form in other marvel
projects
let's watch i mean i i threw daredevil
in there even though he's technically
not part of the midnight suns you know i
think he's marvelous
but um no we haven't talked about any of
that you know it was the question was
like which avenger would i like to hang
out with or something i was like yeah
you know i think it'd be cool to see him
with the midnight suns because that's a
comic uh that i that i that was part of
part of my research i found midnight
sons which i thought was really fun and
also it's new and it's different we
haven't seen that yet um
you know but again it would have to be
you know if if the story's worth telling
if we have like a real hit on it but
there's no it is there's no official at
all
talk or even unofficial talk of doing
midnight stuff not yet
there's we're unofficially talking about
it right now man let's get the ball
rolling let's see we'll see i mean we're
definitely gonna see moon knight pop up
somewhere else right like this is you
know definitely no i think it depends if
people watch the show and they're into
it you know
i mean i feel like it's a safe bet that
people are going to be into it right
well i'm so man i hope so but
right on